as john lewis was laid to rest in
atlanta yesterday he was described as a
hero
a legend a gentle humble giant and a
loving caring friend there just were not
enough accolades to describe this man
his funeral was held at the ebenezer
baptist church where he worshipped many
many times
those honoring him called on americans
to continue on his path
toward his righteousness and equality
cbs this morning's saturday co-host
michelle miller is in atlanta
michelle you did a great job yesterday
you and nora i loved watching our
coverage
it was a really really powerful ceremony
yesterday i can't imagine what it was
like to be there
it was uh thrilling at every turn to see
history in the making and certainly we
know that his legacy will live on
as a man whose fight for equal rights
was seen across the world
he loved america until america learned
how to love him backwards
it was a ceremony fit for an american
hero
civil rights leader john lewis was
remembered for his unstoppable fight for
equality
his everlasting humility and his love
for
all hundreds gathered outside the
ebenezer baptist church to watch the
service
inside twelve-year-old tybree faw gave a
touching tribute
john lewis was my hero my friend let's
honor him by getting in good trouble
and three former presidents shared how
he shaped the nation
john and i had our disagreements of
course
but in the america john lewis fought for
and the america i believe
in differences of opinion are inevitable
elements
and evidence of democracy and action i
just loved it i always will
and i'm so grateful that he stayed true
to form
i suggest since he's close enough to god
to keep his eye on the sparrow and us
we salute suit up and march on
in his eulogy the nation's first black
president barack obama
called lewis a man of pure joy and
unbreakable
perseverance john lewis did not hesitate
and he kept on getting on board buses
and sitting at lunch counters got his
mug shot taken again and again
america was built by john lewis's
he as much as anyone in our history
brought this country a little bit closer
to our highest ideals the former
president told a story about speaking
with congressman lewis
after he joined the senate he said he
walked over to him and said
john i'm here because of you when we do
form a more perfect union
whether it's years from now or decades
or
even if it takes another two centuries
john lewis
will be a founding father of that fuller
fairer better america
and soldiers escorted that flag-draped
casket outside of the church
john lewis's favorite song happy by
pharrell
blared through the congregation there
were more than a few people dancing in
their pews
he was then driven through the streets
of atlanta past
the city council city hall here where he
served
for five years and on to southview
cemetery
where he was buried next to his beloved
wife of 40 years
lillian it was an incredible service
gail i
can't imagine anything
more touching certainly a history lesson
for us all
no he michelle he was such a treasure
and i think we can't help but smile when
we think about yesterday
because it was as sad as it was it was
also a celebration of his life
and one of my favorite moments was bibi
and carvin winans
who wrote the song and then performed
the song at the service i thought that
that was a very very special thing there
were so many special moments yesterday
there there were and and a call for all
of us
to to act uh to to you know act as
citizens
and it was something i think he smiling
down on
a man of action yep he has certainly he
has passed the baton to all of us now
let's see what we do with it there's
still a lot of work to be done thank you
michelle
and again really really great job i was
so proud to be part of the cbs family
yesterday watching all of you